but we're going to begin with the latest
Fallout from a very chaotic day at
America's airports you heard all about
it yesterday more than 10 000 flights
were delayed and more than 1300 canceled
yesterday after the FAA ordered a
nationwide ground stop due to a computer
glitch Nationwide everything shut down
and travelers may still be affected
today Chris Van Cleave is following all
this he's at Reagan National Airport
that's right outside Washington D.C
Chris good morning how bad do you think
it could get today
well good morning today should be better
than yesterday the FAA says it appears
it was a corrupted database file that
kicked off this whole mess that brought
the nation's Aviation system to a
screeching halt today that system is
working but more than 500 flights are
starting the morning delayed
a sea of red delay boards and parked
planes from coast to coast halted flyers
for hours Wednesday morning
I'm working to understand why backup
systems failed to keep the notice to air
mission system running the primary notam
system started going down Tuesday
afternoon it had to be reset early
Wednesday leading to the nearly
unprecedented Nationwide ground stop the
No Time system is basically a system
whereby potentially safety related
information can be relayed to those who
use the airspace former NTSB chair and
CBS News Aviation safety analyst Robert
sumwalt is a retired 737 Captain so is
stopping all flights the right call
I'll give the FAA the credit I think
that in a in an abundance of caution
they stopped all airplanes from taking
off and I believe that's the right thing
to do this system failure comes after
another FAA computer issue delayed
flights at Key Florida airports just
last week Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge you've been very critical of
the Airlines and their operational
challenges uh are you going to be as
critical a D.O.T here because this was a
this was a failure on your watch of your
systems we're gonna own it we're going
to find it and we're going to fix it do
people need to worry about another
failure like this tomorrow well what
people need to know is that we will not
allow anything to take place that is not
safe but this is precisely why our Focus
right now is on understanding
identifying and correcting anything
related to the root cause of how this
happened in the first place
a growing list of lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle over on Capitol Hill
are demanding answers about what
happened yesterday the FAA does say
while its investigation is continuing it
does not appear at this time there were
any cyber security threats that led up
to this failure Vlad
all right Chris thank you very much
appreciate it